Okay.
Should be back live.
Hi.
I have returned from RLC.
It's a heck of a week. Busy. Not as easy
as a conference to work as I thought it
was going to be. Um, but it was good.
Uh, particularly with the award.
Huffer won a best paper award
for resourcefulness and reinforcement
learning. just posted it five minutes
ago here
and the full talk is now available
on X as well as
I can get rid of the horrible
default
uh recommendations
right here.
Watch it on YouTube. You can watch it on
X
quite nice
that.
And um
hopefully with that we should get
another little spike in growth as people
come see the library.
Want to keep that trend going. Guar the
puffer. All right. So we have some fun
stuff to do today. Um,
so I have a lot of research ideas
uh following the conference and we're
going to just start implementing them.
Congrats on the award. Did you do
anything special to your stream post
today to have it send mobile
notifications? No, I did not. Um, I
didn't do anything. There's not even
anything that you can do on that for
uh for X. Like that's just not a thing.
It's just if you follow then it will
sometimes show up either in your feed or
on the like the right side of your um
your Twitter account.
Uh I'm going to try
since I just got back from RLC.
I want to try a bunch of kind of crazy
stuff on the research side.
I'm going to talk a little bit about um
where's that upper max one?
We're going to try on the remote
machine.
Uh are my machines down
or am I just on the wrong terminal? Hang
on. Something is off. Let me figure out
why um
why this is not working
Uh, why the hell are all of my machines
down?
I have to go take a quick call,
I think.
Yeah, I got to go take a quick call. I
have no idea why the hell all of my
machines are down,
but I will go do that and then we will
be we will be right
lovely.
Oh man,
guys that I have there aren't even there
to reboot the machine. So, I'm going to
have to work on this locally for a bit
and then in a couple hours they should
bring them back online.
Hello, FBRR. I've seen you in the
Discord. Thank you very much. Um, and
hey, James, it was good. Got the award
and everything. Um, talk to a bunch of
people. Have some research to do. We're
going to have to steer a little bit
though. I guess I'll just have to
implement on my local.
Hey, that's toine. How's it going, man?
What's good? Um, buffer is doing well. I
have a bunch of research to do. I got to
take a look at the Robocode stuff if
you've done anything there because if
actually that'd be a really good
environment to have uh merged in. But
yeah, so
the slightly annoying thing about this
is I literally don't even have my editor
set up on my local
Actually, I do. I have this set up. It's
just not recognizing my config, I guess.
Um,
let me fix this real quick just so I
have something to do for the next couple
hours. Like, I can actually functionally
write some stuff.
I should just be able to grab this from
um here and then we should be able to
get started. Thank you very much, Finn.
I owe you um I owe you some drones, I
think.
Uh, did you send me I'm sorry I've
missed a bunch of messages because I've
just got back from um conference and
crashed for a day or so over the
weekend. Did you send me like a new
ready to order drone thing or not yet?
Cuz I'm very happy to just quickly send
you a drone if I can get you started on
that.
I didn't realize the polling rate for um
telemetrics would be one per second or
whatever. That's insane.
That's like absolutely insane.
So, I got a whole bunch of research to
start on, but if you have a parts list
or something that I can just real quick
order you, I'd be happy to do that.
I don't know what the heck happened
here.
We're going to give the current setup a
bit longer. Maybe we can hack it. Uh, if
you need a drone, I will absolutely just
order you one. It's just you're going to
have to find something durable enough
that it's not going to break into a
million pieces if you crash it
instantly. But if you find a bigger
drone that's like several hundred bucks
or whatever, that's fine. I'll just send
it to you. I'd very much like to get
this thing working. Um because pretty
much as just for reference here, right,
as soon as you have a cool demo of a
drone, uh that's going to let me start
looking for contracts. And obviously,
you know, if we get a any sort of
contract with a drone company, I'll be
able to pull you both in paid on that.
I'd love to have you guys be able to
like get some return out of this, work
on some really cool stuff, right? And
see it get into into use quickly.
Yeah, somehow this is like the wrong
noxious, you know. It's probably cuz
it's a bun 220 and it's like super dated
or whatever.
Even better.
Not really at all, right?
Yeah, this dev environment sucks.
I'm trying to think what I can do real
quick to like fix this or like get
something workable. And it's just
this is why I wanted to have my other um
I can kind of just start working on it,
but this is going to be very painful
with the amount of code that I have to
actually edit
to not have like my b like even my super
basic dev environment and just be in
whatever the hell this this.
There's not an easy way around it,
though. I guess I'll just have to deal
with it for now, which sucks.
At some point, I'm going to have to get
like either a new machine or reinstall
this machine or whatever, but we'll
we'll deal with this for now. Okay, so
here's the uh the actual plan. Let me
tell you guys a little bit about what I
want to work on here.
if I just can get myself a couple terms
open.
Um,
I got a lot of ideas from RLC about
stuff that is relatively promising.
Uh, some of these are ideas for
environments. So, I have some cool ideas
for a very simple test suite of
environments is going to let us do a lot
of qualitatively new research. It should
not take me too long. It's just the
details are very important. Based on B
Suite, we'll be an extension to that.
Well, native new environments in Puffer
of course. Um, but the other thing I
want to work on is sort of imitation
learning, imitation learning with purely
online data. So, or not purely online
data, but no expert uh expert data,
let's say. So, pretty much you have to
collect all your own data, but you don't
do RL at all. You do imitation learning.
And I want to see what that does because
in my mind at least I'm really not too
tied to the algorithms uh that we use in
RL at all. Like the important thing
about RL to me is the collection of new
data, the interaction. And if the
algorithms change completely and still
have that property that that works well,
uh that is totally fine by me.
And one of the reasons I want to do this
is because basically
this is the only thing that actually
seems like it consistently works is
imitation learning. Um offline RL
um without like expert data uh off
policy. I talked to a bunch of people
and like it seems like a lot of the even
the algorithms that are not super fancy
that have presented as like oh yeah this
just works they really don't work. Um, a
lot of the sort of Deep Mind era off off
Paul stuff is kind of just like it's not
like they have a magic thing that's just
way better than anything that we have.
Essentially, I was kind of under the
impression that there actually was
something to all this sample RL and it
seems like at least pure offpaul stuff
doesn't quite work. So, we're going to
try this other new thing.
Okay.
And I'm going to do
so I get the
just so I get some crazy syntax
highlights.
Maximum eye pain. All right. Um, drag
this over. Just need this one file.
This can be puffer train puffer
park.
Um
2 minutes to train cartpole is
horrendous.
Why did you switch back to Windows from
Abuntu? I didn't switch. This is uh this
is like a random desktop in Palo Alto
that I just happen to have. Yeah, I hate
this setup. Believe me, I would like to
be on a native Linux machine, but I
don't want to take the time to go like
figure out what data I have on this and
reinstall it. I I'm probably just going
to get a new desktop here at some point.
Yeah, believe me, this is awful for
devs. You're way better off on native
Linux. All right. Um, I'm trying to
think what the best way is to get this
started.
And I just like add this.
What if I just add this here?
You only need observation and actions,
right? We're going to do uh behavioral
clothing. I believe that should be all
we need.
So,
old
hobbs.
So now we have gold observations, gold
actions.
I'll leave it as the same size I
suppose.
Oh, we need rewards as well, don't we?
We need the gold rewards
because otherwise we can't tell when to
resample, right?
I think we just need
this though. We're not even going to
need advantage estimate or anything
crazy as that is.
And then when we get to the start of
train,
Oh,
I don't like how this didn't uh pull
solve.
We'll do pong instead.
segments horizon. So you thumb this way,
right?
Way to go with the award. Thank you,
Kvert.
I just put the full talk online. So if
anybody wants to watch this talk later,
it's on X and it's also on YouTube.
And hopefully you'll forgive the uh
small advertisement.
We do have a business as well.
announcements incoming project you were
getting any new there are well there are
a few other things potentially there are
a few things in the works uh there's
definitely research side stuff to look
at so there's this imitation learning
thing there new environments to look at
and there are a few new areas we've been
building stuff out in that aren't yet
public off topic I want to build a 1v
one turnbased game four that does
selfplay target turnbased like to call
agents turnbas your checkout
uh you could modify our connect form to
make it work that way pretty easily.
Yeah. So the one really obnoxious thing
with turnbased dems and I and it's just
pure infrastructure I haven't found a
great way to do this without messing
everything else up uh up yet is you just
make a multi- aent environment where you
ignore the actions every other time step
or whatever for each agent and that
slightly messes with advantage
estimation. It's really not amazing, but
um and it's also like a 50x slowdown in
effective data, but uh that's probably
the best thing to do for now. And at
least for Connect 4, that should be good
enough. That's what I would just do for
now.
Like selfplay is really obnoxious for
with LSTMs especially to do fully
correctly in turn-based games
specifically.
I actually do want to do a bunch of like
selfplay RL research soon. Uh I'm going
to I would start with stuff that isn't
turnbased, right?
And then it's just uh we just have to
figure out the little bit of info change
for turnbased to make it make more
sense.
So how do I do this here? Um I want to
do the port
both of these
Uh, best
x
All right. So we do like this. Now we
have the indices.
Now, how do I index?
What's the best way to do this
operation? I have the indices.
I want to merge them together.
cuz I can't stack the entire buffer is
the annoying thing, right?
I guess I could as an initial thing.
That's so stupid to do it that way
though, isn't it?
What if I just do it this way for now
just to see if I can get anything right
before I try to make the super optimized
implementation?
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. We'll just do it the
stupid way for now, right?
Guess I'm refreshed or something. I
usually can't type this fast. That's
kind of funny.
All right. So, now
we have our rewards tensor. We've got
this. Got our best indices,
observations, actions, old rewards.
Yes. Yeah. Now we have our
our total action set.
I probably want to change a whole bunch
of this, don't I?
Well,
It's not entirely clear to me to be
honest because like
it might be that you also want to do
your RL step. Why don't we just keep
both?
We'll keep both.
And we'll add this like additional.
We'll add this additional thingy. I'd
say
actually we should do this one first,
right?
Yeah. You know, this is what we should
do is actually I see. So, we're going to
put this
we're going to put this up here.
So, this is the original loop, right?
All right. Now, you've done your entire
loop. Okay. So, now you're going to
resample and fill the gold.
All right. So we have right here
we have a random indices for this.
Now we get observations actions don't
need anything else at all.
The kind of crazy thing about this is
how simple this is.
All right now we get observations.
Um,
LSTM state's going to have the exact
same annoyance as before, but whatever.
We just deal with it.
value
that is the policy and you do not need
to even sample the logits at all. Right?
Simply take cross entropy. How roughly
does this work? Uh I'm trying to just
set up imitation learning. So the idea
is that we it's online imitation
learning. So the idea is that this thing
is just going to uh gather a bunch of
data, sort it so that you have the best
episodes collected or the best segments
collected, imitation learn that and then
bootstrap where hopefully you eventually
get uh luckier segments and then you
imitation learn those lucky segments and
it bootstraps forever without even
needing rewards.
Well, without training on rewards, you
need the rewards, of course. I don't
know. I had this idea. I have no idea if
it's been done or like if it's been done
competently, which are two very
different things. So, I figured I would
just try
input
budgets
Thank you very much. I just put the talk
up on uh on X right here.
It's also on YouTube.
I'm working on implementing
uh a weird
online imitation learning hybrid as an
experiment in Puffer Lib right now.
It's not the uh recorded talk from RLC.
It is a clean recording of the talk from
uh well of the exact same talk pretty
much from home.
People like to talk
I recorded it before I left, but then I
left it um unposted till just now.
Fully recursive learning from its own
learn data pretty much.
Um there's no way that this just worked
first try. So, I'm assuming that this is
not actually running the code that I
think it is.
Exactly.
Pretty good though that I got all the
way down to here before I broke
something.
Yeah, because like the thing is my gripe
with all the imitation learning work is
like oh as an alternative to RL. It's
not an alternative to RL if you rely on
expert data. Just not how it works.
Can't even get expert data in a whole
bunch of domains. But if you can use the
same formulation and you can do it with
fully online data with of course being
very easy to mix in expert data if you
have it that is very valid.
I have no idea if it works
cuz uh I mean that's kind of the idea,
right?
It's so funny to me like how I'm writing
this code which would be considered
perfectly normal code anywhere other
than puffer lib and it's like paining me
how slow I know this is going to be
compared to puffer standards just with
like the redundant copies and things.
Kind of funny. All
right. was randon.
Ah, so this gets
Uh
Yay. There we go.
All right. So, that's your imitation
loss.
Is the build still sad? What build that
guy?
Title of the stream. God damn it. Did I
forget to
I I totally forgot to do that. All
right. Here.
Um
online
All right. It doesn't uh you can't
update X titles, but whatever.
This is why I never switch the title.
Everyone always asks me like, "Oh, can
you title the stream what it's going to
be?" No, cuz I always do this and then I
forget for the next four days like a
total goober.
That should be back up.
Actually, wait. Why the chat hasn't even
been here the whole time? Literally,
nobody bothered to mention to me that I
had this thing hidden up here. Really?
All right, whatever. We'll be streaming
tomorrow. Should be.
Well, now I have at least I have the
chat back here. We'll put the puffer
here. We'll put the chat up here. Um
go here for now.
Actually, can does he fit here? Yeah, he
does.
Buffer. Hey, there. Thought it was by
design today. Nope.
Yeah, you guys have to tell me when I
screw random stuff up. All right. I was
just thinking about all like, oh, this
cool research idea and I didn't check
any of this stuff.
This is like uh I had a great lecturer
in college who said actually you know if
I make a mistake I'm like I'm an old guy
I'm supposed to make mistakes or
whatever. If you guys don't catch the
mistake and just silently nod along it
reflects badly on all of you.
of course I need a good machine to
actually run it on.
At least out of the box doesn't do
anything.
If you could go back, would you get a
PhD again? Ooh.
Trying to think if I could have built
this stuff without it.
You know, I honestly think that we're
going to have to wait a couple years to
see the answer to that question with
Puffer Lib. I think we're going to have
to wait a couple years.
You definitely don't want to ask
somebody like right after they uh
finished their PhD in their first year
or two. the longer term thing.
I think the answer is I'd probably be
happier but accomplish less without it.
So take that for what you will.
Okay, I see. So you're just imitating
garbage here at C.
Does it really never get a reward?
Asking since you have to apply. Not sure
to focus on top university go to any. Uh
I definitely wouldn't
just like do a PhD
for the sake of doing a PhD at a random
university unless you're dead set on
doing that.
Wouldn't trust you without the PhD
because I only care about credentials.
That's funny.
There are actually people who think that
way is the thing. Like it actually does
make a lot of the business side stuff a
lot easier.
I don't have to waste time establishing
credibility.
This is just not getting copied over or
something weird, right?
something is weird if it's just not
getting any reward ever, right?
I suppose it is actually kind of tough
uh without the value function
if you don't have a value function of
some sort, right?
Like there are environments where you
just get a negative one for dying.
So that's going to have you training on
like random data
actually. Okay. How does cartpole um
work on rewards?
Like this is very slowly going up I
suppose.
I was thinking something like breakout
would be
way better because that has like a very
consistent chord structure.
We definitely need to get this thing to
train way faster. play with it, right?
Yeah. So, the reward in that buffer goes
up a little bit,
but this just doesn't work out of the
box at all.
Let me think about why why this is be
happening here.
We probably should have a way to like
dump a data set from a good policy as a
reference, right?
Like if you have good data,
then how well can you learn a policy
from that, right?
That's pretty straightforward to come up
with a way to do that.
You know, I'm actually a little
surprised because I would actually
expect this to work a little better out
of the box. Now, hold on. I want to
think about this a little bit.
is there any way to incorporate a value
function estimate with this?
Like not really, right? Because that's
going to move around. That's the whole
on policiness problem.
But like how do you judge
ultimately you just judge that a uh a
trajectory
with the highest reward is better,
right? That's all you do.
Wait, why is the imitation loss and
entropy identical?
Oh, hang on. Something's screwy here,
right?
doesn't know because it should be
I guess they could potentially start the
same
I'm optimizing entropy. That's a
problem. That's obviously not going to
work.
Oh.
Uh, okay.
Wait, entropy definitely should not be
the same as this, right? Entropy should
not take into account the action.
Yeah, see this is logic's time is props.
There doesn't take into account action.
So, how do we get the same number?
That's super weird. Now,
Not even optimizing the right thing
remotely.
Well, that'll do it. I wish I had my box
back so I could test this faster.
So now they're similar but not
identical.
Go looking for more problems. I didn't
realize that was a terrible mistake.
Um
Okay. Well, that's an immediate
improvement, right?
So obviously we want to run this thing
way faster.
But that actually is at least doing
something. No.
Yeah. Okay,
way better.
Now, as for
how well we can make something like this
do overall, I don't know yet.
Uh, we'd like to see this get above like
the six or seven range, which is kind of
looking about.
If that can do this, then it's actually
potentially feasible.
But
yeah, that's actually kind of cool.
So the idea of this thing right is very
very simple.
It's kind of draws on some ideas that um
have worked in LLMs as well sort of
though I guess be weird to credit it to
that because it goes way older than that
but um it's just generating a whole
bunch of data and then imitation
learning against the best data in there
that you happen to get.
Technically, you could also do like a
step of online RL for pretty much free.
Well, maybe not.
You could definitely mix in online RL
with this if you wanted to, though.
In fact, I might even want to implement
it that way if this if this does like
anything meaningful.
Like what I basically want to do with
this is the Can and we use this to
increase sample efficiency
on its own without the RL. I don't know.
If it happened to work better without
the RL, that would be insane because
that would be like a revolutionary
discovery.
I highly doubt we get that. I could be
wrong, but I highly doubt we get that.
Time is it 6:19. So, apparently in about
less than an hour, I should get my box
back and we can just play around with
some stuff in the meantime.
Play around with the hybrid RL thing.
Yeah, there's a lot of stuff we can play
with before we have it fully fully ready
to go. Be right back. Let me use a
restroom and grab a drink. Um, this is
at least a reasonable enough init.
Right back.
Okay. So,
you know, the more I think about this,
the more this makes sense. And actually,
that's now
that's better than randomly running
around. Yeah.
So, how could this possibly not work,
guys?
and we just add this imitation objective
over the best data that we've collected.
Completely get around off policy being a
thing, right?
Now, I suppose that this result that
we're looking at here is not amazing on
its own. Right?
We'll see what score it gets to
at least get like
a few points higher. Good.
I want to work on something with soft
rigid physics, something more sim based.
Any recommendations or ideas?
uh
rigid physics depending on complexity we
have know our own we just implement our
own stuff for drones
and Sam did that uh that could be done
and extended to six degree of freedom
arms at like an intermediate skill level
project intermediate implementation
skill the math is a little tricky
soft body I don't know about the
algorithms You might actually need an
engine for that.
I'd go look into some of those other
projects though. Like people have
written their own soft body physics
engines
and I'd go look around to see like what
is the minimum complexity thing you need
in order to make something like that
work.
Okay, so this is above random perf here
for sure.
So, let's say that over the next
hourish, while I'm waiting for my boxes
to come back online so I can train at a
respectable speed, um,
let's say I get this thing to run with
hybrid online RL imitation learning,
right? You do the im you do the RL step
so that it's on policy roughly and then
you do as many imitation learning steps
as you want. You have the buffer size
for your goal data be configurable
and then you try to improve the sample
efficiency of your online RL using the
imitation learning.
None. All the boxes are screwed or most
of the boxes are screwed, but I have
somebody that's going to come boot them
in like an hour. Nobody told me that
they were screwed or at least nobody
told me loud enough with how fast the
Discord moves while I was at the
conference. So, I didn't know to have
them rebooted.
They weren't. Looks like they were
going. They went down on August 4th to
me.
at least from um it looks like they've
been down for like several days.
Yeah, some of them have autoreboot, some
of them don't.
We're going to have to go through and
reclaim a bunch of boxes cuz I don't
think everyone's using them.
Yeah. Okay. 8.6. This actually, it's
kind of funny that this just works.
Literally, the first thing I implement
works.
It doesn't work great, but it does work
better than noise.
the monkey ball end if I did rigid body
108 bytes.
What do you mean it's 108 bytes?
I've done a six degree of freedom arm,
but kinematics go way over my head, so
it was super slow.
How did you do a six degree of freedom
arm without doing kinematics?
Math gets a little hairy, you know.
What is online RL getting us that this
isn't getting us is my question.
Well, you do get the value function,
right?
Optimal
Oh, well, you need to do both uh you
need to do both forward kinematics and
dynamics
in order to get like a basic reacher
working.
It's going to be like a fair bit of
math.
That would actually be a very valuable
task to the extent that the first person
that comes and PRs me like an actually
good sixth degree of freedom arm at the
level of the drone end. Um, like that's
actually probably one of the more
promising ways to get into contracts
with us.
Obviously, there's more to it than that.
You'd actually have to help us find some
partnerships with robot companies, but
that's probably one of the easier ones
to do.
Math is a little hairy, though.
Would probably take me like several days
to figure out.
I'm trying to conceptualize here in my
head.
the difference between these approaches,
right?
Yeah, you'll be waiting a while on that
convert.
There's an advantage to doing this,
isn't there?
It's slightly obnoxious, I guess, from a
compute perspective because
what you would like to do, right, is
you'd like to add the imitation loss uh
just to the RL loop. But you can't do
that because if you do it that way, you
make it more off policy, which is bad.
You want to keep it as on policy as
possible
during the RL loop. And then you want to
take it off policy with the imitation
loop.
Oh, wait. Doesn't this Wait, does this
still screw it up or no?
This probably still screws up the value
function, doesn't it?
possibly does still screw up the value
function. Uh that is a positive result
though from like an early experiment.
There are a lot of different ways we
could set this thing up potentially.
Uh, it shouldn't because you should be
passing a done signal bet.
But you can technically, yes, you can
technically mess stuff up depending on
how you it
I don't know how you have it be. Is it
like ignoring an action? Because it has
to be able to see. It has to be like
observe the board state, right?
and then it makes its action and then it
observes the next state of the board and
then there has to be a done after that.
You basically there's a thing where if
you reset it right you can drop either
the first observation of the next
episode or the last observation of this
episode. You have to be careful not to
do either of those uh in this case I
believe.
Okay. So, this immediately performs
better. Um, and we can compare this, I
believe, to the
we can compare this one to the other
ones.
Uh, I definitely need my computer back
to be able to run these experiments. So,
let's just like clean this up and make
this reasonable, I think, in the
meantime.
place.
You're going to There's going to have to
be one uh extra observation before reset
where the action doesn't do anything
basically.
This is stuff you would have figured out
by now if you've been doing your formal
RL
readings in parallel to the
implementation. Yeah.
You did. All right. Do your do your
homework.
That's very much how our work. Yes.
Yes, it does. Bet.
Don't you forget it.
it could potentially be working much
better soon.
Did you get it working, Spencer?
Hey, look at that. We've got Spencer
doing real research. Now,
uh, I'm actually have a decent shot at
solving sample efficiency, or at least
like majorly improving sample efficiency
with what I'm doing now.
Do you need um boxes for experiments,
Spencer?
Cuz obviously
this is going to have to be swept on a
ton of stuff.
Yeah, go for it. I think the tiny ones
are still up. Um,
we have a few of the individual boxes
down right now and they should be back
up in less than an hour.
Yeah. So, this is experimental. Uh,
Spencer's doing discrete value
functions. Yeah, Spencer. So, this thing
I'm working on is pretty cool. Uh, so
what this is going to do is this is
going to keep the RL objective. HL Gaus
and anything that you do it that'll stay
and it'll stay like our one epoch of RL
like we normally do. But then it's going
to let you add in uh however much
imitation learning you want on the best
data that you've seen so far. So this
should allow you to keep like uh high
value data around. Yeah, this should
like let you keep high value data around
and essentially build yourself a data
already applying ideas. Yeah.
Um, if I get this to work, this would be
like puffer four material and this could
well it would have to work very well.
But I think algorithmically this is the
type of thing that could definitely
uh like unlock new applications and be
puffer 4 just straight up.
Like Puffer 4 could literally just end
up being a 500 line change to uh like a
400 line change to Puffarel.
I have to do it while they're fresh in
my head, though, you know. But I sent uh
I did I ran the dish this morning. I did
some weights
and uh I answered all the emails, all
the conversations. That's still on
track, don't worry. Then I'm starting to
do some of this stuff.
I owe Kathy Woo's group some work. I owe
clients some work, but have to at least
carve out a little bit of time to do
this type of stuff. Yeah.
Are you running stuff on one of them?
No, not at the moment. And uh I don't
need I don't need either of them for uh
for a bit. So you can just go ahead and
use both.
The only thing that I will need is I'm
going to need Puffer Max one. um which
is like the single 5090 box when it
comes back up because I'm going to set
that up for um imitation learning
experiments over the next couple Yes.
Uh the point of it bet is to use expert
compute.
start so that it's quick. Start with
running best breakout params on a few
others and compare like just get the two
curves like with HL Gaus and then like
with whatever I had in there for the
breakout sweeps before on like a few
other M's like pong, enduro, whatever
else. Um, and then you're going to have
to rerun an HL G sweep on some of the
more complex ends. Uh, mazes might be a
little tricky because that one's hard to
tune for. If you get better at mazes,
that's really good. Obviously, we're
going to want to do some of the more
complex ones. We're going to try MOA.
Uh, tuning on neural MMO is hard, but if
we can tune and get something on neural
MMO, that would be really good.
Great job at RLC. Thank you.
Conferences are exhausting. They really
are.
I basically crashed. I got home and I
was like, "All right, I got 36 hours of
not doing RL work.
Uh, that was kind of the whole
conference that it was rough.
I'm pretty much good now.
the game idea
mechanics. Yeah, you can do that.
I'm going to work on I'm going to work
on like research side stuff for a little
bit with this just because I think
there's a good chance that this works.
I also have the be sweet thing which is
I think also a good idea.
What?
Some facto
that was a
fly to the previous or what?
Total mini batches.
Got total ILIL mini batches.
need two different opt. No, you don't
need two optimizers, right?
Wait, do you need two different
optimizers if you do two different
objectives like this?
I guess we'll try it like this first and
we'll see.
Yeah, we'll just try it like this first
and we'll see, I guess.
Oh yeah, you can't have these be
different, can you? Damn, forgot about
that.
Not easily, at least, right?
It kind of sucks. Kind of sucks, doesn't
it?
You'd have to make average reward work
in order for this to make any sense.
decent.
If this actually runs nepo
I think that this yeah this gives us our
initial starting point right
Yeah, this is never going to prune
anything off of this, which is good.
So, we can definitely optimize this, but
this is like this should be a decent
starting point, I would assume.
You haven't trained the value function.
You haven't trained the value function,
right?
So I think that what you want to do is
you want to compute
the value function.
Wonder if we want to do the same
sampling thing.
We could pretty easily do that same
sampling thing now.
Wait, you don't need a clipped value
function anymore, do we?
I guess all this stuff I'm thinking
about should be more empirically
motivated.
Why I need my uh my fast box back so I
can play with this messages. Gotten it
back.
Okay.
Well, I can at least put it into place
the code and we can ablade it. That way
I won't have to implement it after.
Yeah, you need like all the freaking
things, don't you?
Boing
ratio advantage.
If we're able to get this advantage in,
then we'll be able to prevent the uh the
advantage function from going stale.
That's the idea. Because if you take the
um the policy too far off value
and if you take it too far off of the
policy,
it'll collect data correctly,
but like the value function will just be
undertrained.
So the hope here is if you keep the
value function fresh,
then you'll still be able to make full
use of your on policy data with the
better policy train via IL.
That's the uh the core idea here.
Now
I do need to go find this ratio
like this online manipulation learning
like data aggregation.
Uh I looked I was looking around for
references and I kind of let's see if
this is let's see if this matches. Um,
so you just you're collecting data
online, you're filtering it for the best
data and then you do imitation learning
on that instead of having any sort of
expert data that you're starting off
with. It's fully bootstrapped
at least that is the goal. Now it's easy
to combine this with online RL
and in that case then what this would
potentially do is uh it would just let
you use less data for the same result.
Sample efficiency hack.
Lots of things we can potentially do
with this.
Is it without reward info? uh the
imitation learning part only uses the
reward information in order to decide
what data to keep, right? So you need
something that decides what data you
actually want to train on. You're not
actually using reward to optimize, but
you're using reward to select your data.
Imitation learning without reward only
works if you have an expert data set,
which is not what we want to do.
Filtered behavioral cloning. Yes, except
that like when you talk about these
methods, right, you're almost always
talking about using expert data and
we're not,
right? You can filter expert data for
the best expert data, but there's no
expert at all here.
Still not offline RL. Offline RL is also
different and it has its own set of
problems.
Offline RL is also still typically used
with expert data, right? expert data
that includes reward annotations.
This is not really either of those. I
don't know if people have done this
before. It seems like something that you
would probably expect to have been done
cuz it's pretty simple, but I couldn't
find any references.
Not always.
Um I mean if you have examples of online
offline RL being done with data
collected fully from scratch let me
knowly
random behaviors. That's also not this
though because if you do it with
completely random behaviors that will
only work if your environment is
trivial. The thing is that you're
actively collecting new online data.
pretty much any environment for which
you can train it with purely random data
is just a trivial problem
I mean you can construct like degenerate
counter examples. Um but for the most
part in practice that is true.
Sounds pretty niche. Well, it's niche in
the sense that I haven't seen research
on it before, but it's not niche in the
sense that if this works, it will be
like it will massively massively improve
the entire space as a whole immediately.
Online data is generated by the agent.
Yes, the online data is generated by a
new tabularasa agent in initialized from
scratch that learns over time.
Yeah, Bed is right though. Like we do
kind of crazy things around here. And
like we do crazy things in a way that
like even if they've been tried before,
uh the way that I'm doing them here is
much more likely to work.
Well, that's yes, that is obviously
true.
Okay. So, I think that this is good and
we can now try this with um a few
different combinations of settings
and we can see whether this can be made
to work better uh with the IL and the
loop than not. Now, the problem is, of
course, that
I need my um my box back.
My box back. Yeah.
And
let me go check if it's back up on tail
scale.
No, they haven't gotten home to reboot
it yet.
Could go steal box zero for a bit.
I might go do that.
I'll try seven if I can't get zero
working. I use a restroom real quick
though and then uh I mean there's no
point in running a 30 minute experiment.
That should take one minute. I'll be
right back.
So, uh, Spencer says he's not using box
zero for a little bit. Try that.
Here's what we're going to do. We're
going to commit this.
much better. Right.
Get reasonable speeds,
We're going to comment this whole loop
out next for a baseline.
Okay, so we do have stable training on
the original,
right?
Funny, it's a lot slower on a 4090 than
it is on the 5090, but that is stable
training,
stable task solve.
90 million steps
pretty much.
That's the baseline to
happens if I just trim the value loss a
bit. Does this crash it?
Yeah, this nan's out.
Well, it's possible I just have this
thing defined or wrong, All right.
still ns out. Was actually doing pretty
well before it nanned out.
This doesn't hand out. It just doesn't
do as well, right?
least this is not completely crashing
our learning here.
It's worse by a lot. Not completely
crashing it though.
The only thing I can think about this is
the stale value function, right?
And like somehow
do I just have the value function
calculation wrong? Is that all it is?
I can't see what else it could be.
But this seems fine. I guess the other
thing is it's not clamped,
right? The value function is not
clamped.
I have to avoid getting too far off the
freaking policy, isn't it?
Okay, this is the same clip value loss
now from before
Well, hang on. It's still I was about to
say it's stable, but it's clearly not.
Maybe you need to do plus
hands out at 200. Eh,
now
Is there any fundamental reason they
should be unstable? I don't think that
there is.
Right. There's no fundamental thing that
uh jumps out at me as to why they should
be unstable.
Particularly with a clipped loss like
this.
Was there any warning or did it just
like all of a sudden explode?
Imitation went to Nan. Then everything
else went to Nanitation.
How did imitation laws go to?
They didn't make any sense.
should be like the easiest most stable
loss ever. No,
the straight up behavioral cloning loss.
policy weights must be screwed up,
right?
I know it's not fancy fancy cross
entropy. It's literally cross entropy
just scaled badly.
I don't think it is just scaled badly
though, right?
The value loss being screwy.
Um, it's training like okay, I'd say bet
it's not like noticeably
I don't think it's any better than the
baseline yet.
This does seem like the type of thing
that has to work though.
Yeah, but like the goal is okay, can we
solve breakout in fewer steps by
spending more compute.
Weird to me that we can't
the value function not want to train.
I'm almost positive that it's the value
function, right? Like this thing not
wanting There.
Yeah.
Do we get in?
We do this.
Yeah, there's no RL here at all.
Betation
Okay. I mean, this is like up to 26
score.
Very cool. Well, it's not doing super
well yet. It's doing better than random.
So, the question here, right,
hypothesis one is, can you completely
replace RL with self imitation? That
seems kind of hard to do without a ton
of compute
um or even if you can do it at all. Uh
option two is like can you improve
sample efficiency?
This actually did worse.
should be able to do this and do better.
Let's see.
RL for material science. Yeah, we will
be doing that as well. Why does that not
show up in my dashboard? I see it on the
screen.
This doesn't seem to be doing massively
better or anything.
Oh, this does do work.
Okay.
Well, this will be super sample, right?
Very fast.
Do you care more about wall clock or
steps? Uh, for your experiments, I would
say I care more about wall clock.
So, HL G shouldn't make it any slower
really. So, it should be similar,
Spencer.
Like, you should end up with very
similar results in terms of um wall
clock, but like the experiment should
take not really any longer to run.
Quite hard to get this thing to
bootstrap.
Yeah. You know, like I would think that
doing a longer horizon would help.
Like it is learning something, but it's
not
Not a great signal, right?
well, wait. Does this this solves cart
pole with no RL,
right?
That did just solve cart pole, did it
not?
Oh, hey. Wait, that almost solves pong
as well.
Wait, that's that's almost Pong solved,
too.
like 200 bet
195.
It almost solves pawn.
Yeah. So, hang on. This there is
something to this. There's something
about the structure of the M though.
Back from the conference, I see any cool
new inspiration. Yeah. We're currently
solving RL problems without RL,
which is kind of crazy.
Well, no, but it makes sense that this
would work.
What about a dense reward like pupper
drone?
trajectories aren't even expert. That's
the point.
The full full bootstrap problem.
Uh let me go find another problem that
we can do.
doesn't work on this.
However, you watch what I've missed so
far. I mean, I can give you the TLDDR of
it, right? So, we're doing um
we're saving a buffer of data from the
agent. The agent's initialized from
scratch. We're saving a big buffer of
data from it. Uh, but we're only saving
the top end trajectory segments like
ever from any time that we run the
agent. And then we're running imitation
learning on those top segments.
Basically, we're seeing if this thing
can bootstrap when it from a totally
random agent. Um,
yeah,
worked on. What are some other M's I
would expect like a weak learner to work
on.
Oh, that doesn't work cuz it's
multi-discreet, right? I haven't added
multi-isport yet.
Convert single discrete.
Not
Or is going down, not up.
Racer. We can try that.
I try snake as well.
Snake is like a good simple multi task.
I mean,
you can't say that's doing nothing,
right?
especially for like a very first take on
this.
Four
is not one normalized. So, I actually
don't know how high it's supposed to go.
I think it was like three or four or
something.
I mean, that does actually do something
though.
Tripled score from baseline.
Are you sure?
I thought that the baseline was like
three or four score. No,
Eval will show. Yeah, I'm on a remote
box. I have to like do something for
that.
Bye snake.
It's like somehow run out of better
data.
That could be an entropy fail though,
right?
Let me try with entropy.
Is this technique people
please use for robotics RL?
No, this isn't like this is new. Um, it
seems simple enough that somebody
probably has done it, but if there is a
reference, I don't know it.
I wonder if it's like stuck on the
ability
to have enough reward in one segment or
something.
like the fact that it does cart pull
instantly, right?
And pretty much pong
think is multi multi- aent. Yeah,
self imitation learn. Is it an actual
established thing, Finn, where people
like bootstrap imitation learning off of
nothing?
Like I've seen people do this for
completely different reasons and like
weird context,
but I haven't seen this specific thing
done.
Need to make sure I'm not making that up
because there was a paper
the fact that it does something like
this, it's like flashes of brilliance,
right?
I had a suspicion. I'll explain this in
a second if I'm right.
Yeah. So, this is what I thought. Um,
so this has the best early curve I've
ever seen on Neural MMO 3.
Yeah.
Guys, this is the Yeah, this is a
real thing.
No, it's not going to solve it. Let me
explain in a second.
I will explain in a second why this is
so important.
Yeah. So, this is pretty much the same
algorithm as I came up with, I think.
Let's see.
No. Well, this portion is the other
thing that I tried pretty much. Um, but
this is without I'm just doing this
portion right now.
There's also prioritize replay as a
potential.
So, this is it is pretty close. I will
say it's like it is pretty close.
Who the heck is this paper from?
Some like random paper.
Okay.
So, here's the thing, guys. So, what's
hard with neural MMO? Um,
the reward
from random actions is incredibly sparse
at the start. So, like it's very very
difficult to get the reward a few times
at the start. And if you're only getting
a reward like a tiny tiny fraction of
the time, it's very difficult to latch
on to that reward and learn.
But what this does is this is actually
going to save the trajectory segment
that contains the reward and learn on
just that. So like let's say you get 10
million samples and only get like five
good rewards. Well, at least those five
good rewards are in the batch of s of
data that you're training on.
the what I don't think that this
algorithm as written is going to like
scale to solve the whole task or
anything
but like
this is qualitatively very very
different from just on policy RL
yes bet so it kind of solves
it solves the like the sparse
exploration in in some sense
This is not world model stuff.
This is substantially more powerful
along certain axes,
right? Having a world model does not
tell you how to get reward. You have to
roll out like a whole bunch of different
planning and your planner is going to
suck at the start. So, that actually
doesn't fix it.
I think it's pretty different from that
bet, frankly.
Make sure I'm not trolling here. I'm
not. See, this is commented out fully.
Why does this not work on like breakout
or snake or stuff like this?
a little bit more concerned about snake.
Okay. So breakout has long segments.
So it's not it's not just an entropy
thing, right?
and set some crazy entropy just to be
sure.
Oh yeah, we're making sure that we're
actually training on this, right? Yeah,
we've got it.
All right, who has hypothesis?
This is working like ludicrously well on
some environments for some portions and
not so much on others.
You're stuck imitating length 64
segments.
You don't have like a value function
bootstrap or something like that.
Do inverse RL to optimize that for what
would that do for you?
inver inverse uh inverse RL is to like
estimate a reward function when you
don't have the data labeled. We do have
the data labeled. Why would you do that?
So I mean we can confirm that setting
the entropy coefficiency for high
destroys the training.
This does confirm though at the very
least that there are problems where this
idea of keeping around
prior good data
is very powerful.
solves ponging, solves cart pull. Crazy
good on neural MMO in like seconds.
Actually behaved kind of predictably cuz
like I was pretty confident it would
actually do that for neural MMO.
That's why I ran that experiment.
I didn't just do that randomly. I
thought, oh, you know, that's an
environment with super sparse roads, so
it makes sense.
Then why does it just get stuck at a
point?
Well, Breakout doesn't have the same.
Okay, there's like some degenerate cases
with Snake, I think.
But with breakout,
take his multi- agents
one. All right. Well, we'll try
breakout. Let's see if you can find a
reason for breakout. Right. Breakout
here.
It does train.
H I'd have to copy it to my local.
There's no point. We're very confident
in breakout as a task, right?
We've used it extensively.
It's a very small like change.
We haven't changed the end of it all.
I think we have all the information that
we need though. Bet from the design of
the algorithm.
You collect trajectory segments. You
label them by reward.
That gold reward is telling us the
average reward of steps over that
segment. It's still going up the whole
time.
What if breakout also rewards the random
shortest path
filter by all cases the ball starts
initially
straight down reward over trains on that
stuff.
Yeah. So, it would technically the best
thing for it to do, right,
uh would be to select the segments where
the ball's about to strike the paddle
and then um the ball strikes the paddle
and then it like it hits another brick
and bounces it back. It should be able
to fit that in a 64 segment, I would
think.
But you're to you're totally right that
it could be something weird about the
trajectory segment bounds. Uh, oddly
though here it this did not do better by
training on more data potentially
overfitting.
We can change BPT horizon, but it's
going to change the batch size and other
things.
It's very hard the way that this is set
up to even include a value function of
any type.
Let's see if we can actually just get it
to solve the task
um
by any sort of
here.
something like it moves corner well but
tries to stay alive in the uh I actually
know that it cannot be that because that
gets you like seven Four.
super long run just to see if it's
stably increasing.
I mean, so far
it is like a clean, stable curve.
I do want to see if it ever gets stuck.
there. Also, we should keep in mind
breakout is a slow start environment,
right? Where like you have to get to a
certain point before it starts learning
more quickly. So, this might not be a
horrible horrible failure, right?
Like if it just hasn't gotten to that
point in the curve early on, it could
very well be that once this thing gets
to like 50 or whatever score, it just
takes off like a rocket.
If we look at the gold reward here,
right,
the gold reward is like not
substantially getting better.
It's still going a little bit, but like
this is not good training speed.
This is also without reuning hypers.
Fair
possible those have shifted. So most of
the hypers that we would even normally
tune no longer will exist with this.
We're also we're not getting the same
like curve shape. We're not getting like
the exponential
takeoff here, which is
probably the more concerning thing is
not seeing the uh the thing like take
offed
turning.
No, that should just be like
there are problems where at a certain
point, right, you need to find a little
bit of reward and once you do, it's very
easy to learn from there. You would
think you'd get the same with the
imitation case, right, where like once
you learn to hit the ball enough, you'll
have rapidly you'll have better games
than others and you should get like a a
quick signal for how to learn
Think
if we had expert data, this just works,
right?
We we're going to have to ultimately try
that I think is going to be the thing
for tomorrow because
like I've done enough stuff on this to
see that there is clearly some potential
and we're going to need like expert data
IL for just for comparison sake like you
know we train a breakout agent we dump a
big data set and we see
uh how good by comparison we train on
app
like what size data set do we need to
train a good agent with IIL if we're
doing that etc etc
will it just go all the way well you got
to keep in mind we've been training
breakout for nearly a billion steps Now,
oh, this is not great.
Like, it has been stably improving the
whole time, but not anywhere near what
we would want.
cycle of marginal.
Um, well, how do we set this up?
How do we set this up differently?
Like the concept of generating
like the con like imitation learning as
a concept works, right? If you have
expert data, then you can imitation
learn.
It would seem that you should be able to
bootstrap then, right? Like if you just
take your best trials and you pick the
lucky ones or whatever. Yeah, we'll do
it this way. I mean, I guess technically
you can't train on lucky. There are
degeneracies here as well.
Not sure if work. Well, I mean RL works
somehow, right?
Yes, bet. That's what we were trying
before. You can do that. There just some
issues
actually. How did they do it in here?
Did they update
update their value function.
See, they didn't even update their value
function at all here.
Oh, I don't even know if they have a
value function. They're just doing like
reinforce.
No, they do.
better at the task.
Um, I don't know if that quite does
because like
RL is literally learning by trial and
error at the start, right?
It's trying to do credit assignment to
rewards.
Actually, RL is a very hard objective to
learn. Behavioral cloning is a very easy
objective to learn.
I mean, we've literally seen it solve.
So, we've seen it solve two easy tasks
like instantly,
and we've seen it like do better than
random on like everything.
And we've also seen it
we've seen it do
the first hard exploration bit of a very
hard task. Way better than our
state-of-the-art RL.
You know, oddly enough, this would
probably pair really well with search,
right?
Yeah, this would pair like really well
with search.
Let's see if we can get the base thing
to work first.
Well, but Breakout, like the curves for
Breakout, the thing is Breakout and Pong
have very similar curves, but Breakout
just takes longer.
Do I have like a breakout curve? I They
look like this. I mean, they look like
the neural MMO curve, honestly. The
breakout curves. It's like Yeah. And
then it sol like and then it goes up
really fast and solves. Same as pong.
Same as a lot of tasks.
Okay, let's try like a slightly dumber
version of this. E,
I'll try a slightly dumber version of
this.
Trying to see if there was like stale
data steness issues.
game plan to weave this into puffer and
proper move method. The goal is to play
around and see what works, right?
How can I say that this will be the main
training method when this is like random
new research for an idea I just thought
of? Right.
Okay. So, this gets 22.
If I don't drop the rewards, what do we
get?
0.79 as well.
Okay, so this ended up being it was very
slightly better to drop out some indices
Like if you made this horizon equal to
one, you would only ever get data where
you have the reward, right?
The fact that you don't have the reward
here is actually kind of bad because you
can't do any credit assignment at all.
You do offline RL instead of behavioral
clothing here. Is that the play?
You even set that up. Much harder, isn't
it?
It would make more sense though because
you have the record function, I suppose.
though it makes it harder if you want to
actually add expert data
Why I don't understand why it is the
case that
long and breakout are pretty
substantially right
and breakout are like really
substantially
Okay. Next question.
These are separate tunes, right?
This
Okay, that is a bit better.
Still not like insta solving our task by
any means.
It still just has this property of being
really slow. Like it's not taking off at
all.
get us to 27.
Let's like
Fact that more updates doesn't do
anything is also weird to me.
it's not like
it gets like sort of stuck.
And we've seen that if we just run it
for super long, we can get it unstuck.
You want more research gems like squared
all for?
Yeah. So, actually that's the other
project I have planned. I'm back from
RLC is if you look up B Suite heat mine
paper it's like a diagnostic end suite.
Um
we're going to do a much better version
of that as a core project. Uh it's not
an easy project though, mind you,
because like implementing the
environments is going to be very easy.
But um actually coming up with good
clear-cut environments that are properly
motivated, like a minimal set that
actually tests what you care about is
hard. very very hard.
Down to help. Sure.
If you go look at the B Suite paper, I'm
warning you that this is like actually
very hard research. Like this is a task
that I would expect the vast majority of
RL researchers to fail on. Um because if
you look at the B Suite tasks, they're
like kind of motivated, but if you
actually really think about it, like
they actually don't do a good job of of
being like a minimal test suite and they
kind of just throw a bunch of buzzwords
out like exploration and generalization
without really really clearly thinking
about mechanistically what they're
testing.
I'd say that this has been pretty good
progress overall though, right?
We see that the simplest instantiation
of this algorithm
uh can solve several different
environments.
We'll have to think about whether like
I mean it would be kind of insane if
this just replaced all RL, right?
I think that that would be kind of an
insane thing to expect.
The question is like does this combine
nicely with RL? Does this benefit from
data scale? Right? There are a lot of
things that we'd want to test here.
The fact though that this actually does
something on neural MMO 3 is kind of
insane.
Like I don't to be clear I don't think
that if I just run it for longer on that
it will actually be better. But like the
fact that it latches on to something
that hard that quickly is very
impressive.
Do a quick lunar lander run. We don't
have lunar lander in here. Did somebody
PR it?
Oh, Kinvert has a bunch of nice little
PRs.
Yeah, there's no lunar lander, man.
Somebody was working on it, I saw, but
it hasn't been PR. I don't know if that
was you or not.
I'm going to go do some thinking about
this. I got to go get dinner, folks. Um,
I will be back streaming tomorrow.
But this is pretty cool to get like
initial results day one of this.
I'm going to have to think very
carefully though about how how I go
about this and such.
Actually, just commit this before I
forget.
my everybody must be dreaming. Uh there
is the like in like the original lunar
lander which is unusably slow. There's
somebody who is working on Lunar Lander
in the Discord, but I don't I don't
think we've gotten a PR from them yet.
So, we kind of can't uh can't do
anything with it just yet.
Okay,
dropped a quick PR
uh in the
dev channel. Let me see. Linky, you
caught me just in time as I was about to
go.
Is that 800k SPS?
Wait, vision test works.
I do need to ask if you'd prefer I
include Rayb's camera as a file or as an
actual project.
Do you mean as an actual import?
Uh, you can do either. If you want to
just like
if you want to modify our ray download
so it includes the camera, that's fine.
Either one works.
Wait, 800k SPS? I'm going to have to see
this.
If you actually got the thing to render
at 800k SPS, that was awesome. Last time
we checked, like it wasn't actually
computing anything, right?
I will be around tomorrow to look at
that. You have that to look at.
If
no link key I don't think this is a
reasonable thing to include
using rays now what does that mean
kitting uh I don't think that this is a
reasonable thing to include link key
Because
if you set it to auto,
like I think it tries to mimic the
number of M's or whatever, you
definitely don't want it to be equal to
just the number of cores regardless of
how many M's you have. That will just
throw you a hard error if they're not
divisible.
Mimicking the camera by doing 64 rays
and getting collisions on those.
So, I guess for a basic scene, yeah,
that works. That's super funny.
That's actually a good test to have, to
be honest with you.
I'd be interested to see how it works on
like my higherend hardware. I'll take a
look through the PRs tomorrow. Is that a
satisfactory answer though, Linky? For
now,
I want to head to dinner in a second.
Okay. Well, I'm going to call it for the
day, folks. Um, thank you for tuning in.
If you're interested in this work
generally, a few small things in case
you didn't see it. This
uh talk is on X at J Suarez 5341 same as
my Twitch handle everything else. Um my
full talk the uh the paper that won an
award at RLC only a few minutes like 7
minutes 38 seconds if you want to watch
that
discusses all the stuff in Puffer go
ahead and take that look at that. If
you're interested in my work more
generally or you want to get involved,
buffer.ai,
star the repo. Really helps me out a
ton. It's free. Just star it. You can
jump in the Discord if you want to get
involved with dev. Other than that, on X
we have resources. Of course, this is
going to open a popup. But yeah, on X we
have resources for beginners
and just lots of RL material in general.
These guides in particular cover
everything you need to know.
So, thank you folks and I will be back
tomorrow.